speaking of people can't be taken
seriously number two gwen berry was uh
on some kind of show she was the
olympian
turned her back on the national anthem
the hammer thrower
uh i'm not even sure what show this is
but she was defending she finally after
like a week
has come up with some kind of defense
for her behavior but i don't find it
terribly persuasive let's
take a listen well originally we were
not even supposed to be on the podium
during the singing or the playing of the
national anthem
when we were back in the call room the
directions were
that we were going to be introduced to
the crowd um before the anthem was going
to be played
or after the anthem was going to be
played no one made any mention or any
notion that we would be on the podium or
had to be on the podium
during the singing of the national
anthem i want to make that clear
those were our directions either before
or after
no other event group that i know of
stood on the podium during the plane of
the national anthem
however when we went out to introduce
ourselves to the crowd
coincidentally the national anthem was
playing and they asked us to stand
on the podium and then the anthem played
in that moment i feel like it was a
setup because
i was those were not the directions that
was not the intent
the intent was we would be introduced to
the crowd either before
or after the singing of the national
anthem
in which if we had that option or if i
knew
that i was going to be on the podium i
would have chose something else
now i just want to ask what is it about
the national anthem or that whole
scenario that made you feel so
uncomfortable why didn't you want to uh
you know acknowledge that part
history if you know your history you
know the full song of the national
anthem
the third paragraph speaks to slaves in
america our blood being slain
and and piltered all over the floor it's
disrespectful and it does not speak for
black americans
it's obvious there's no there's no
question
huh it's obvious there's no question
well if you know your history the third
paragraph
of the as she puts it of the national
anthem talks about blood being
what was it slang and
piltered is it the horse she used
blood being piltered all over now i
admit um i don't know
the uh the third and there are i think
four stanzas
to the national anthem um like almost
everybody else
i know the first one i don't know the
others by heart
um but when i first heard that claim
from her i i immediately knew
that that can't be right because
piltered is not a word
it kind of sounds like a word that could
be a word it's like it's like the kind
of word that you you you throw out and
scrabble
just on a flyer and you hope that no one
challenges it because it kind of sounds
like it could be a word
so you give it a shot because you got
that you got that triple word score
in reach and you just throw pilter down
and someone goes
pilter what is that oh yeah pilter wait
you've never heard
you've never heard the word pilter are
you serious go ahead and challenge you
you'll lose a turn go ahead i don't care
that that whole move but as it happens
um
pilter is is not a word i actually did
look it up because i thought i almost
felt like
am i having a stroke or something is
that that to me it sounds like that
can't possibly be a word
i i did actually google it just to make
sure i'm not wrong on this
not a word i can confirm that um
what does the national anthem actually
say what is she referring to
so let's read i'm not going to sing it
but let's
let's read the part that i assume she's
referring to
um it says and where is that band who so
vauntingly swore
that the havoc of war in the battle's
confusion
a home and a country should leave us no
more their blood has washed out their
foul footsteps pollution
no refuge could save the hireling and
slave
from the terror of flight or the gloom
of the grave and the star-spangled
banner in triumph duth wave
over the land of the free and the home
of the brave it's actually a great
uh it's actually beautiful um
notice nothing about being piltered all
nothing is being piltered all over the
floor
i don't know what it would look like for
a thing to be piltered and the reference
to slaves
and hirelings okay that that is not a
reference to african
slavery i go back to what we discussed
at the start of the show yesterday
okay she says people need to know
american history she obviously doesn't
know
a damn thing about american history um
and this is
by the way backing up again um
this cl this was not her reason
for turning her back on the flag she
turned her back on
on a flag just out of a general sullen
sense of i hate america and i don't know
why
really it's i hate myself
um and i'm projecting that those
feelings of resentment and
and failure i'm uh i'm i'm
projecting them out onto america
that's what a lot of this is about all
of these morons who
hate america so much and it's and at
some level they do
feel that way but um
these are these are basically like kids
who go around saying no one likes me
everyone hates me
that kind of thing but uh so
that was her reason for doing it and
then she did it and she got this to this
big big negative reaction and backlash
and for the last few days she's been
looking for a reason
and she probably she looked up the
lyrics of the national anthem
and she discovered for the first time
that it has other stanzas and then she
saw the word slave in there she said oh
oh yeah this is the reason this is why i
did that
but as we discussed yesterday um
the form of slavery that existed in
america
the the type that she's referring to
horrible thing
not the only kind of slavery that's ever
existed on the planet
it's existed for slavery has existed
existed as an institution across the
world for thousands of years
so not every reference to a slave
is going to be about um this slavery of
african slaves in america in this case
it certainly isn't
this verse is talking about clearly
talking about the british here
they are the band that so vauntingly
swore
right they're arrogant and haughty and
all of that
like those damn brits tend to be
and um and the hirelings and slaves are
a reference
i seems to me to the fact that the
british have the british army had
mercenaries and men impressed into duty
against their will
as opposed to the volunteer forces in
america
so it's kind of a dismissive reference
to the british forces saying oh they're
hirelings and slaves they were forced to
be there
these are mercenaries as opposed to the
free men who volunteered for service
for the united states that's what it's
talking about
it takes a little bit of of translating
and interpreting the flowery language
but it's pretty clear
not a reference to african slaves
so the reason she gives makes no sense
but it doesn't matter because again this
is just her
really this was a gut visceral reaction
because she does she hates her country
she hates the country that she's
representing
and going to represent the olympics
listen
hit that subscribe button right now do
it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated